James Cameron has been mouthing off
about star wars the force awakens come
on Jim don't you have anything better to
do like you know the sequel to avatar
you're supposed to be working on I'm
Lucy and welcome to your quarter portion
gamespot news update while star wars the
force awakens is the most successful
film ever released in north america it
was held off the top spot worldwide by
avatar and Titanic now James Cameron
directed both of those box office Titans
and he's spoken about what he thought of
the latest Star Wars movie and it's not
hugely positive well George Lucas is a
friend of mine and he and I were having
a good conversation the other day about
it I don't want to say too much about
the film yeah also I also have a lot of
respect for JJ Abrams and I want to see
where they're taking it next you know
see what their see what they're doing
with it I have to say that I felt that
George's group of six films had more
innovative visual imagination yeah this
film was more of a retrenchment two
things you had seen before and
characters you see before and it took a
few baby steps forward with new
characters so for me the jury's out I
want to see where they go Cameron
himself is currently working on the
sequel to avatar the film is yet to
begin production and currently has no
official release dates in April it was
reported that Cameron plans to shoot no
fewer than four new avatar movies
simultaneously it's old variety we have
decided to embark any truly massive
cinematic project making for epic films
each of which stands alone but together
forms a complete saga so what do you
make of Cameron's comments do you agree
or think he should keep his nose out of
it let me know in the comments below the
more movie and video game news make sure
you keep it gamespot
you